[Musik]
habe ich noch rechtzeitig geschafft
okay es ist soweit wir haben 250 tausend
abonnenten auf und doktor watson
erreicht und ich bin als erstes mal
unglaublich happy und super froh und
sehr dankbar auch deswegen dankeschön
als aller erstes mal an alle leute die
diesen kanal hier in der letzten zeit im
letzten sechseinhalb jahren abonniert
haben 2015 haben den kanal gestartet
damals nicht noch ganz alleine mit der
zeit habe ich ein team aufgebaut die
videos mit größerer aufwendiger geworden
ich hoffe auch ein bisschen besser und
ja es war eine krasse reise wir sind das
bald von 210 video wir wollen noch
mindestens 200 weitere videos machen
wenn ich sogar noch mal deutlich mehr
wir starten bald dennoch meinen ganzen
neuen abschnitt von doktor watson wozu
ich aber natürlich zu viel erzählen kann
was ich erzählen kann ist worum es in
diesem video hier geht ja vielleicht
dieses video hier letzte woche gesehen
dass über fahrräder und unsere städte
und genau dieses video haben wir die
heim tessins mäßig begleitet wir wollten
euch nämlich erzählen wie entsteht ein
doktor watson video wirklich von der
ersten idee über die recherche bis hin
zum skript schreiben über den dreh bis
hin zur postproduktion mit einem schnitt
und allen animationen wie entsteht dann
doch kurzen video das dann in eurem
youtube profit landet und genau das ist
dieses video hier wir wollen euch zeigen
wie viel arbeit in unseren videos steckt
und wie wir die genau machen viel spaß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jedes doktor watson video fängt
natürlich mit einer idee an
alle können ideen beisteuern die werden
dann erst mal gesammelt und innerhalb
unserer fünfköpfigen redaktion
besprochen passt das thema überhaupt zu
uns und zu doktor watson können wir
darauf ein komplettes video aufbauen und
auf welche aspekte wollen wir uns dabei
fokussieren
wir wollen das auch nicht abschaffen es
gibt immer autos geben
und ihr werdet immer die freiheit haben
auto zu fahren
aber was ist mit der freiheit nicht auto
fahren zu müssen
dieser sei eigentlich ein step
zurückzugehen und mal den kopf gebissen
aufzumachen und dann erstmal zu
realisieren wie abhängig von autos wir
sind weil für uns alles ist eigentlich
total alltag total normal aber man zu
realisieren ist kann auch ganz anders an
das auto ist unsere städte zerstören ist
glaube ich vielen klar die einflussnahme
ein großer lobbys auf stadtplanung ist
nicht klar das ist das enthüllen das ist
der drama spect wenn alle eine idee gut
finden dann bekommt das video ein
konkretes abflugdatum von hier an wird
es allerdings noch mindestens vier
wochen dauern bis das video tatsächlich
auf youtube landet und ihr sehen könnt
die reise hat gerade erst begonnen
dieses video hier hat jonas übernommen
der sich ab jetzt tagelang in studien
bücher und alle möglichen artikel
eingräbt um eine grobe outline für das
grips produzieren zu können also für die
recherche von doktor watson videos ist
wichtig dass wir das erstmal quellen
finden also das ganze thema erstmal
einarbeiten
im groben überblick an
und dann gehen wir natürlich den
bereichen tiefer kubicki vergeben wollen
dass wir diese richtung gehen nach dem
kurzen überblick geht es dann halt in
studien rein das ist würde ich sagen
auch wahrscheinlich derzeit auf
billigste art parallel organisiert
unsere produktion alles für den dreh und
für die finanzen wir wissen können wir
uns nicht alleine von youtube einnahmen
finanzieren daher müssen wir regelmäßig
mit werbepartnern kooperieren und sind
auch auf eure spenden über bachelor
angewiesen um zu entscheiden mit wem wir
zusammenarbeiten und vor allem mit wem
wir nicht zusammenarbeiten wollen führen
wir eine blacklist mit unternehmen die
gegen unsere werte sprechen die einfach
nicht zu uns passen und auch die
trennung von redaktion und werbung ist
uns wichtig deswegen ist es auch die
aufgabe der produktion
kooperationspartner auszuwählen und auch
die sponsoren teile für die videos zu
schreiben so kann sich die reaktion rein
auf die inhalte konzentrieren
eine gute quelle mal aus dass wir sie
von anderer seite noch mal bestätigen
können das nimmt man das zwei quellen
prinzip on top ist es natürlich noch
besser das versuchen wir auch eigentlich
mal zu machen dass wir uns noch einmal
expertinnen und experten in verbindung
setzen die vielleicht in dem bereich
forschen an instituten an universitäten
aber vielleicht auch aus der wirtschaft
wenn es ums konkrete geht dass wir da
auch noch mal bestätigen können hält das
was wir herausgefunden haben die
zusammenhänge die wir hier gefunden
haben sind die wirklich so wenn man sich
im akademischen bereich bewegt ist es
natürlich auch für uns immer elementar
darauf zu achten ist das preview von
welchem journal kommt das gab es der
vergangenheit etwas was so ein bisschen
fischi war da hatten wir natürlich auch
drauf natürlich nicht für alle aus der
redaktion sprechen aber ich persönlich
mache das so dass ich die quellen die
ich habe erstmal den oberthemen cluster
unterteile also hier geht es quasi um
den theoretischen aufbau von irgendwas
das ist bisher praktisch gemacht worden
das sagt die zukunft also ein bisschen
wenn man unsere videos kennt weiß man
dass wir ungefähr an solchen themen
bereichen entlang haben
das ist natürlich besonders wichtig für
uns dass halt dieser weg von quelle
dass man das nachvollziehen kann also
wie kommen wir im endeffekt zu dünnen zu
den aussagen die wir dann im video
treffen
deswegen machen wir natürlich auf
quellen in der video beschreibungen
sehen kann aber auch darüber hinaus
dokumentieren wir halt einfach unsere
recherche das skript geht ab dem ersten
entwurf immer wieder in feedback
schleifen hin und her wir setzen hier
wert auf einen mindestens sechs augen
prinzip damit das skript die ganze zeit
auf den prüfstand gestellt wird dieser
prozess dauert so um die zwei wochen und
passiert eigentlich immer mit mehreren
krippen gleichzeitig damit wir überhaupt
unseren wöchentlichen output halten
können und dann endlich ist es soweit
ein fertiges script es kann gedreht
werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die bundesregierung hat als antwort auf
die hohen energiepreise ein sogenanntes
entlastungs paket beschlossen neben dem
neuen euro ticket für schätzungsweise 2
5 milliarden euro wurde auch
vorgeschlagen benzin und diesel zu
subventionieren für 6,6 milliarden euro
in das es ist wie die 196 ich muss sagen
ich bin nicht wirklich
wir machen das einmal die woche ist dass
gewisse routine drin inzwischen einen
safe space hier wenn ich mich
versprechen kann ich das wiederholen wir
können immer wieder von vorne starten
wir nehmen sowieso alles zweimal auf und
machen quasi einmal das in der kloster
wo das dann quasi nicht ganz so wichtig
ist man rechne ich mir erst mal ein
wenig verfahren und einem mehr weit ist
dann das was wir am meisten nehmen und
da muss ich dann auch zu performen aber
dann weiß ich auch schon an welcher
stelle mache ich diese geste an welcher
stelle zeige ich nach oben hin auch die
infokarte wie betoniert genau das wo man
sich der pause machen um uns mit der
stimme nach oben gehen muss nach unten
gehen deswegen freue mich jetzt schon
sehr gut gemacht das komma steht weiß
wie es funktioniert kinderhaus seit
1996 videos das passt bei manchen
unserer videos kommt dann auch noch ein
dreh außerhalb des studios dazu mal
wollen wir einen besonderen einstieg für
ein video mal einen sketch drehen oder
die reisen für interviews und placement
in ganz deutschland herum so auch für
dieses video hier für unsere
zusammenarbeit mit juli waren wir
tatsächlich schon einen monat vor dem
eigentlichen dreh auf der polis mobility
messe in düsseldorf unterwegs haben
abgedreht hatte ich ungefähr zwei
stunden gedauert mit allem drum und dran
für wahrscheinlich am ende 10 15
sekunden im video und jetzt fahren wir
noch eine stunde zurück zurück im studio
hier drehen wir den moderation style
mindestens zweimal komplett durch und
beide einstellungsgrößen mitzunehmen
dabei kommen für so ein normales doktor
watson video gerne mal über 90 minuten
material kann
[Musik]
hey wie wir alle wissen entsteht der
film ja erst wirklich um schnitt
aber im ernst auf dieser sd karte ist ja
jetzt sozusagen die rohmasse und die
muss jetzt erstmal zum eigentlichen
video gemacht werden das sind jetzt 60
bis 90 minuten material die erst mal auf
unserem zentralen datei server landen
auf dem unser sechsköpfiges post
produktionsteam zugriff hat und dann
entscheiden wir im team erstmal der
dieses video jetzt übernimmt in diesem
fall ist dass maria
das erste was maria jetzt macht ist aus
den verschiedenen einstellungsgrößen das
material zu sichten und die besten text
zusammenzufügen damit sozusagen dann
einmal der native unterbau des videos in
einem zusammenhängt aber das ist ja erst
der anfang von allem denn damit dass
doktor watson video zu dem wird was ihr
kennt fehlen jetzt ja noch ganz ganz
viele elemente die im laufen von der
zweiwöchigen post produktionsphase die
jedes video von uns hat noch dazu kommen
das sind die bilder musik sound design
die angepassten haben unser team über
das wie wird schon mal ein ganzes video
gemacht haben aber auch solche sachen
wie texteinblendungen zitate in
dokumenten oder auch wenn es das video
benötigt aufwendigere erklär animation
und dafür ist zum beispiel der fall
verantworten
stefan ist neben mir einer der beiden
enders bei uns im team kann also nicht
nur schneiden sondern auch leise
animationen in die timeline zaubern das
sind manchmal einfach kleine
verzierungen die den videos ihren
letzten schliff geben aber häufig sind
es auch quasi schon eigene erklär filme
die helfen komplexe wissenschaftliche
zusammenhänge zu verstehen stefan ist
aber nicht nur für animationen zuständig
er ist auch einer unserer grafik
das heißt er ist unter anderem
mitverantwortlich für die neuesten
fernseher ist die ihr immer in eurer abo
box kleiner perfekt dazu vielleicht habt
ihr es schon mal mitbekommen dass sich
die farm nails und titel unserer videos
nach dem upload manchmal klang heimlich
ändern das liegt daran dass wir meistens
sogar schon während des schreibprozesses
gleich mehrere ideen für titel und
thumbnails entwickeln und nach upload
schauen wir dann mal welche davon am
besten performance aber so weit sind ja
noch gar nicht es ist noch ungefähr eine
woche bis zum ablauf maria hat
inzwischen eine erste version des videos
mit den nötigsten bausteinen fertig und
auch die natürlich feedback optimieren
wieder feedback wieder optimieren die
version des videos die ihr am ende auf
youtube seht ist nicht selten eine
version vier jahre oder sogar version 5
[Musik]
und dann ist es endlich soweit das video
geht online
private denn danach kommen ja eure
kommentare rein die wir immer sehr gerne
lesen und wo wir uns feedback draus
holen werden wir merkten nah daran den
fehler gemacht und wollen wir das auf
keinen fall ein zweites mal machen und
dieses ganze mit euch austauschen auch
kommentare antworten kommentare lesen
kostet natürlich auch nochmals zahlt die
erkenntnisse die wir aus den kommentaren
und dem video selbst sammeln nehmen wir
dann direkt mit ins nächste projekt wir
wollen uns stetig weiter verbessern
aber so gesehen endet hier die reise
nach ungefähr 200 arbeitsstunden über
vier wochen zeit und inzwischen arbeit
von 13 menschen die alle dafür sorgen
dass wir wöchentlich hochladen und zwar
in der qualität die ihr von uns gewohnt
seid und deswegen erlaubt mir vielleicht
noch mal an der stelle den letzten
hinweis auf unsere patrick long seite
wir jetzt gesehen habe stecken wir sehr
viel zeit in jedes einzelne doktor
watson video und zeit heißt dann auch in
diesem fall geld geld das wir nicht
immer zurück bekommt vor allem wenn wir
keine werbung schalten können oder nicht
werbung schalten wollen weil es mit dem
thema einfach nicht vereinbar ist auf
pagerank gibt es ganz viele verschiedene
parks und vorteile die ihr nutzen können
zum beispiel könnt ihr videos frühjahr
vor allen anderen gucken oder ihr könnt
im abspann genannt werden oder ihr könnt
sogar von mir persönlich genannt werden
wie zum beispiel robben der den rang des
professors hat und johannes der den
allerhöchsten rang hat den ehrendoktor
vielen dank dafür wichtiger ihren doktor
an euch vielen dank fürs zuschauern und
wie immer bleibt neugierig hattrick und
euer team doktor watson
[Musik]
kann man ja dafür wollten 198 seele
zweiten
verstehe ich das denn richtig dann so
[Musik]
nah ist ein bisschen war ein bisschen
krassen
a4 bei twitter
[Gelächter]
[Musik]